después de recorrer los vasos sanguíneos
de nuestro cuerpo una hormona se
encuentra con un receptor creado
específicamente para ella por las
células objetivo y la forma en la que la
hormona interactúa con el receptor pasa
en una de dos formas muy características
y vamos a estudiar en este vídeo cuáles
son el primer mecanismo importante de la
acción hormonal en la célula son los
segundos mensajeros vamos a empezar con
los segundos mensajeros porque son un
poco más confusos lo que básicamente
sucede es que tenemos una hormona que se
une al receptor de la célula así que
vamos a dibujar una célula y su receptor
y también vamos a dibujar una hormona
unida a él el proceso de esa unión en
lugar de sólo estimular el efecto pone
en marcha una reacción en cadena que
lleva a la liberación de segundos
mensajeros dentro de la célula así que
vamos a dibujarlos tenemos estos
segundos mensajeros liberados
ellos los que estimulan cualquier efecto
que se desee ya sea que se libere
insulina o que se ingrese glucosa a la
célula o cualquiera de las otras
innumerables cosas que pasan en nuestro
cuerpo y que son controladas por las
hormonas entonces con el fin de que
podamos observar como esto tiene lugar
en la célula previamente dibuje una
imagen que nos ayudará a entenderlo es
importante que sepamos que estos dibujos
no están a escala ya que todo esto está
sucediendo en un nivel atómico y los
átomos son muy pequeños pero esto es lo
mejor que puedo hacer para explicar este
proceso lo que tenemos en esta imagen es
un receptor en rosa está localizado
dentro de la membrana celular
esta es la bicapa lipídica de la
membrana celular por acá estamos adentro
de la célula y por acá afuera también
tenemos en la membrana celular la
proteína gm
se le llama proteína g porque se fija a
las moléculas que incluyen nucleótido de
vanilla y es la misma g de las bases de
adn que nos resultan más familiares
actualmente está unida a una molécula
llamada one nothing de fosfato gtp en
rosa y veremos como esto cambia también
tenemos esta enzima adel y la tos y
clase que está en la membrana de la
célula y recordemos que las enzimas
aceleran la reacción por lo tanto
podremos ver cómo la adenilato ciclasa
acelera la reacción pero este proceso
empezará cuando la hormona que este
enlace con el receptor se vea más o
menos así entonces tenemos a la hormona
ligada al receptor y una vez que la
hormona está unida al receptor va a
cambiar de forma y esto le permitirá
interactuar con la proteína g
entonces se verá algo así
podemos ver lo que sucede cuando la
proteína g interactúa con el receptor en
un complejo hormonal va a intercambiar
ese gtp con el que empezó es decir él
cuando cindy fosfato por g t p es decir
básicamente intercambia una guanina
unida a dos fosfatos por una wan y la
unidad a tres fosfatos eso permite que
la proteína g se mueva a través de la
membrana celular e interactúe con el
adenilato ciclasa esto activa el
adenilato ciclasa que a su vez facilita
la conversión del atp que es la moneda
energética de la célula en la mpc es
decir adenosina mono fosfato cíclico
entonces tomamos el atp adenosín
trifosfato y creamos el adenosín mono
fosfato cíclico además tenemos dos
fosfatos adicionales
pero es la molécula de amc la que activa
la proteína dentro de la célula cuyo
efecto es realmente el objetivo inicial
de la hormona activación de la proteína
finalmente este sistema se reinicia pero
no antes de que varias enzimas adenilato
ciclasa sean activadas dando como
resultado una gran producción de mps así
que llamamos a esto una amplificación de
la señal en teoría no referimos a la
amplificación de la señal como una
hormona que se une a un receptor y ese
proceso genera una reacción en cadena
que conduce a una gran producción de mpc
que ya sabemos que es adenosina mono
fosfato cíclico esto significa que se
requiere menos hormona para activar la
proteína o los efectos que se desee
los segundos mensajeros son un medio por
el cual la hormona actúa en la célula
sin embargo este efectos usted de
maneras diferentes para muchas células
de hecho todavía no se conocen todos los
mecanismos de los segundos mensajeros
las hormonas
hay muchos otros segundos mensajeros
además del mpc en conclusión cuando la
mayoría de las hormonas en tu cuerpo se
unen a la superficie de la célula
activan una serie de reacciones que
inician una respuesta dentro de la
célula
es muy similar al uso de un proveedor de
servicio telefónico nosotros como
personas vamos a dibujar nos como
algunas veces no podemos comunicarnos
directamente con las otras personas
debido a la distancia a la conveniencia
oa la falta de eficiencia usamos el
servicio telefónico para proyectar
nuestra voz a la otra persona a través
de una conversación telefónica es decir
la conversación telefónica dirige
nuestra voz a las personas con las que
queramos comunicarnos o tal vez tengamos
la libertad de escribirle un mensaje de
texto que le transmite algún mensaje
intencionado a alguien con quien no
podamos comunicarnos directamente por
cualquier razón
esto es muy similar a como los segundos
mensajeros ayudan a las hormonas que no
se pueden comunicar directamente con el
receptor dentro de la célula las
hormonas peptídicas o las catecolaminas
son hormonas que no pueden cruzar la
membrana celular y usan segundos
mensajeros para poder comunicarse
ahora bien el segundo mecanismo
importante de acción hormonal en la
célula es el de primer mensajero ciertas
hormonas como los esteroides o las
hormonas tiroideas pueden cruzar la
membrana celular y eliminar este sistema
completo de intermediarios que
establecimos anteriormente así que
pongamos otra membrana celular la
hormona va a cruzar la membrana celular
y se une a un receptor que se encuentra
en el sito sol o en el núcleo
podemos imaginar un núcleo que tiene
dentro adn pero cuando la hormona se une
al receptor ya sea en el citoplasma o
dentro del núcleo ese proceso de unión
afectará directamente la transcripción
en el núcleo o la traducción en el
citoplasma de la proteína activada por
la hormona
este proceso tiene bastante menos pasos
que el sistema anterior de segundos
mensajeros porque de nuevo se basan en
el hecho de que estos esteroides y
hormonas tiroideas tienen una base de
lípidos que son capaces de pasar a
través de la membrana celular por lo
tanto no requieren ajustar una
maquinaria adicional de cualquier manera
ya lo tenemos estos son los primeros y
segundos mensajeros estos son los dos
procesos importantes para la acción
hormonal en la célula objetivo